in one and beamed think it's premature
to the defending our that's an offensive
foul in its core enjoy me
[Applause]
take a look at this the elbow they're
gonna take it oh absolutely yeah
this is gonna be a flagrant one nod him
in the chops
absolutely Wow this is gonna be a
flagrant one
it was hard it was high an accountant
right
in the shops then the chin on the
jawbone so this is a fight channel we
got rocky around here right well Alan
there's only 20 oh my goodness that was
and
here this oh that is a shot question is
does that warrant a level of flagrant
- look I saw Audrey Drummond get thrown
out versus aunty takubo in their game
one which I didn't think that was a
flagrant - Bella drew blood here on
Allen on the swinging elbow also a bead
here and there's a look at the two
fragrance question is unnecessary and
excessive contact looking at that replay
that's pretty excessive the question is
do these referees have enough to call it
here because I didn't think Drummond's
was a flagrant - this is absolutely a
full a flagrant one the question is I'm
not gonna offer it I think they're gonna
call this a flagrant one
gonna be two shots
[Applause]
[Music]
she shot around in the ball and bead
he's got two fouls maginificent took
brooklyn achievement was 40 to 40 we
began the season 8 and 18 feel like they
had nothing to lose the players kind of
came out with those statements after
game
[Applause]
right there that one at the stripe 71
percent free-throw shooter and bead with
a conversation in Allen with another
free throw